People magazine reported that Johnny
Depp is in financial trouble because if
his 2 million dollar a month lifestyle 2
million dollars a month is what it takes
for Johnny Depp to live I was really
skeptical I thought that's not possible
I looked into it it costs a lot of money
to be Johnny Depp check it out here are
some of his expenses
there's airplane hangar for scarf
storage forty thousand dollars a month
fake British accent coach two thousand
dollars an hour racoon based eyeliner 13
thousand dollars a day ongoing in vague
investigation into What's Eating Gilbert
Grape
ten thousand dollars a month Lindsey
consultant 3500 ollars an hour paying
people who saw the Lone Ranger to forget
they saw the Lone Ranger 32,000 dollars
per person
VIP jumped the line pass at
participating Panda Express franchises
two thousand dollars a month
strip writer who it's weirder please in
the margins of every Tim Burton
screenplay
$2,500 a week and finally financial
advice from Nicolas Cage 25
you
you